alors madame la Première ministre il est
temps d'atterrir quand retirez-vous la
réforme des retraites
pour vous répondre la parole ton
ministre du Travail du plein emploi de
l'insertion Monsieur Olivier du somme
merci à Monsieur le Président Mesdames
et Messieurs les Sénateurs madame la
ministrymane ce matin effectivement avec
la première ministre et son habitation
nous avons reçu l'interdicale toute
l'incertitude l'interf syndicale puisque
l'ensemble des organisations étaient
présentes c'est une étape importante qui
a été franchie une réunion importante
nous avons pu écouter chacun d'entre eux
et l'échange entre le gouvernement la
première ministre et les organisations
syndicales a été un échange respectueux
nous avons entendu le désaccord répété
de leur part sur le relèvement de l'âge
de départ et pour certains d'entre eux
sur la fermeture des régimes spéciaux
nous avons aussi évoqué un certain
d'autres sujets je pense aux carrières
longues je pense à la prévention de
l'usure professionnelle je pense à tout
ce qui fait finalement l'accompagnement
des carrières et un certain nombre de
mesures qui jalonnent à la fois la
carrière professionnelle et les
retraites le désaccord qui persiste
entre les organisations syndicales le
j'aimerais sa majorité sur la question
de l'âge n'a pas permis d'approfondir
plus avant les thèmes que je viens
d'évoquer nous avons entendu comme vous
madame la ministre que le représentant
de l'intersydical à la sortie de cette
réunion avait indiqué que les mêmes
organisations syndicales souhaité
pouvoir
ultérieurement travailler sur ces
sujets-là nous y sommes favorables et la
première ministre a eu l'occasion de
leur dire que nous sommes prêts
lorsqu'ils seront prêts lorsqu'il le
souhaiteront à ouvrir l'ensemble de ces
chantiers à l'occasion de cette réunion
nous avons pu aussi la première ministre
a pu plus singulièrement encore le
rappeler la conviction du gouvernement
cela nécessitait de cette réforme
nécessité face à un déficit n'hésitez
pas à un système qui semble n'agissons
pas va se dégrader si vous permettez
cette expression va aller dans le mur
donc nous souhaitons mener cette réforme
aujourd'hui le texte est au Conseil
constitutionnel nous attendons sa
décision pour ensuite pouvoir mettre en
œuvre cette réforme
de croire que c'était important de son
temps pour entendre les syndicats enfin
je m'excuse fallait être sourd mais
archi sourd pour ne pas avoir entendu
leurs arguments auparavant les sujets
que vous évoquez carrière longue
pénibilité c'est au cœur des débats que
nous avons eu ici et pour la réforme
alors Monsieur le Ministre puisque ce
serait nécessité fondamentale pour la
France
si vous ne voulez pas revenir sur le
retrait
organiser un référendum n'ayez pas peur
du peuple demandez-leur leur avis et
leur arbitrage c'est peut-être la seule
façon de sortir de cette entêtement qui
est le vôtre nous exigeons un référendum
où le retrait
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]